un simple bip en caisse pour faire un
don de 2 euros ou plus c'est la
quatrième année consécutive de
l'opération microdon dans les
supermarchés des yvelines comme ici à
voisins le bretonneux des associations
de la coopération internationale peuvent
ainsi récolter des fonds pour alimenter
leurs projets dans les pays en voie de
développement
donner des petites sommes un nouveau
modèle de générosité on pense que c'est
un changement d'usagé qui évoluent avec
les générations les générations des
seniors plus ont un mode de réponse à la
suite aux sollicitations aux dons qui
est traditionnellement un coupon papier
un chèque et on pense que ce mode de don
va laisser place petit à petit à des
générosités dit générosité quotidienne
avec des actes de dons dans la vie de
tous les jours
les associations sont choisis par le
département
exemple avec bucs tiers monde qui oeuvre
pour l'éducation au burkina faso 270
adhérents et 35 ans d'action comme avec
ce lycée construit en 2005 dans une zone
rurale du burkina à la frontière du togo
à la rentrée 2012 il y à 1000 élèves qui
rentrent donc au lycée 2 you et parmi
ces mille élèves il y a deux cents
enfants qui sont pris en charge par les
adhérents de buxy au monde 200 enfants
dont on paie la scolarité la nourriture
est tous là de la sixième à la terminale
l'année dernière nous avons récolté
quasiment 3000 euros 3000 euros c'est
pas tout à fait la moitié c'est vrai
quatre mois de nourriture pour les
enfants
donc c'est très important cette année 18
associations posté dans 23 points de
vente ont pu bénéficier de cette
organisation
chaque opération leur permet de récolter
entre 700 et 2000 euros
près de 120 manifestations ont été
organisées en france depuis la création
de micro dons en 2007